a bit of a classic implicit
differentiation problem is the problem
y i don't want to write it that thick
y is equal to
x
to the x and then to find out what the
derivative of y is with respect to x and
people look at that oh i have x to a you
know i don't have just a constant
exponent here so i can't just use the
power rules how do you do it and the
trick here is really just to take the
natural log of both sides of this
equation and this is going to build up
to what we're going to do later in this
video so if you take the natural log of
both sides of this equation you get
you get the natural log of y is equal to
the natural log of x to the x
now our power rules or i guess our
natural log rules say look if i'm taking
the natural log of something to the
something this is equivalent to
i can rewrite the natural log of x to
the x as being equal to x times the
natural log of x
so let me rewrite everything again
so this if i take the natural log of
both sides of that equation i get the
natural log of y is equal to
x times the natural log
of x
and now we can take the derivative of
both sides of this with respect to x so
the derivative with respect to x of that
and then the derivative with respect to
x
of that
now this is we're going to apply a
little bit of our a little bit of the
chain rule
so the chain rule what's the derivative
of this with respect to x what's the
derivative
of our inner expression with respect to
x this little implicit differentiation
so it's d y
with respect to x
times the derivative of the whole thing
with respect to this inner function
so the derivative of natural log of x is
1 over x the derivative of natural log
of y with respect to y is 1 over y
so times 1 over y
and that is equal to and the derivative
of this this is just the product rule
and i'll arbitrarily switch colors here
it's the derivative of the first term
which is 1 times the second term so
times the natural log of x
plus
the derivative of the second term which
is one over x times the first term so
times x
and so we get
we get
d y d x
times one over y is equal to natural log
of x plus this is just turns out to be 1
right x divided by x and then you
multiply both sides of this by y you get
d y
dx is equal to
y times the natural log of x
plus 1 and if you don't like this y
sitting here you can just make this
substitution y is equal to x to the x
so you could say that the derivative of
y
with respect to x is equal to x to the x
times the natural log of x plus 1. and
that's a fun problem and this is often
kind of given as a a trick problem or
sometimes even a bonus problem if people
don't know to take the natural log of
both sides of that but i was given an
even more difficult problem and that's
what we're going to tackle in this but
it's good to see this problem done first
because it gives us the basic tools
so the more difficult problem we're
going to deal with
is this one
let me write it down
so the problem is
y
is equal to x to the
and here's the twist x to the x to the x
and we want to find out
d y d x we want to find out the
derivative of y
with respect to x
so to solve this problem we essentially
use the same tools we use the natural
log to essentially break down this
exponent and get into the terms that we
can deal with so we can use the product
rule so let's take the natural log of
both sides of this equation like we did
last time you get the natural log of y
is equal to
the natural log of
x
to the
x to the x
x to the x to the x and this is just the
exponent on this so we can rewrite this
as x to the x
times the natural log
of x
now we'll immediately so now our
our expression our equation has
simplified to the natural log of y
is equal to x to the x
times the natural log of x but we still
have this nasty x to the x here we we
know no easy way to take the derivative
there although i've actually just shown
you what the derivative of this is so we
could actually just apply it right now
i i was going to take the natural log
again and it would turn to this big
messy confusing thing but i realized
that earlier in this video i just solved
for what the derivative of x to the x is
it's this thing right here it's this
crazy expression right here so we just
have to we just have to remember that
and then apply and then do our problem
so let's do our problem and if we hadn't
solved this ahead of time if we hadn't
solved this ahead of time it was kind of
a unexpected benefit of doing the
simpler version of the problem you could
just take keep taking the natural log of
this and just but it will just get a
little bit messy but since we already
know what the derivative of x to the x
is let's just apply it
so if we take the derivative we take the
derivative of both sides equation
derivative of this
is equal to the derivative
of this we'll ignore this for now
derivative of this with respect to x
is the derivative of the natural log of
y with respect to y
so that's 1 over y
times the derivative of y with respect
to x that's just the chain rule
we learned about an implicit
differentiation
and so this is equal to
this is equal to the derivative of the
first term times the second term and i'm
going to write it out here just because
i don't want to skip steps and confuse
people so this is equal to the
derivative with respect to x
of x to the x
times the natural log of x
plus
the derivative with respect to x of the
natural log of x
times
x to the x
so let's see let's do that let's focus
on the right hand side of this equation
what is the derivative of x to the x
with respect to x
well we just solved that problem right
here it's x to the x the natural log of
x plus one
so this piece right there i'll do it in
a different color
that piece right there i already forgot
what it was x to the x natural log of x
plus one
that is
x to the x
times the natural log of x
plus one and then we're going to
multiply that times the natural log of x
times the natural log of x and then
we're going to add that to
plus the derivative of the natural log
of x so plus the derivative of natural
log of x that's fairly straightforward
that's 1 over x
times x to the x
times x
to the x
and of course the left hand side of the
equation was just
1 over y
d y
d x and we can multiply both sides of
this now by y
and we get d y d x is equal to
y
times all of this crazy stuff
x to the x times the natural log of x
plus one
times the natural log of x
plus 1 over x
times x to the x that's x to the
negative 1. we could rewrite this as x
to the minus 1. and then you add the
exponents you could write this as x to
the x minus 1 power
and if we don't like this y here if we
don't like this y we can just substitute
it back
y was equal to this this crazy thing
right there so our final answer
for this
seemingly well on one level it looks
like a very simple problem but on
another level when you appreciate what
they're what it's saying it's like oh
this is a very complicated problem you
get the derivative of y
with respect to x is equal to y which is
this we'll just back substitute so
that's x
to the
x to the x
times all of this stuff
times and i'll just put it in green
times
x to the x
natural log of x
plus 1
times the natural log of x
and then all of that plus
x to the x minus 1.
so who would have thought sometimes math
is elegant you take the derivative of
something like this and you get
something neat for example when you take
the derivative of natural log you get 1
over natural log of x you get 1 over x
that's very simple and elegant and it's
nice that math worked out that way but
sometimes you do something you take an
operation on something that looks pretty
simple and elegant and you get something
that's hairy and and not that pleasant
to look at
but
it's a pretty interesting problem
there you go